Hello Freak bitches.
Yeah.
So if we replaced a sacred for respect,
I think we'd be.
But it's just noises.
It's one of the things I like about
labels.
Like I liked intent and intent.
Like my,
my idea of sacred is not like God,
like it's not like some,
it's not a deity,
this unnamed unknown word that's been
passed down from person to person.
It's based on personal experience based
on a real thing.
So when I say sacred,
like my love,
my love for my children is sacred,
you know,
like I say it in that window.
I don't say it like in terms of like
hearts and the clouds and all that kind
of jazz.
And when we were talking about like
don't be an asshole to people you care
about,
like doesn't mean it certainly doesn't
mean I'm some sort of a perfect person.
Certain doesn't mean that I have been an
asshole.
And then sometimes when you're
responding to someone else being
retarded or something about being
ridiculous,
you can be an asshole because you don't
have the patience for it anymore because
you don't have the,
uh,
at the moment you don't have the
temperament to charity.
Yeah.
What?
Yeah,
it could be maturity.
It could be you're overwhelmed.
There's a lot of variables.
So like if someone hears this and says,
you know,
Oh,
well man,
I've been an asshole lately.
Maybe I'm a bad person.
Like,
no,
it's just recognizing those moments
where you probably could have handled
something better.
And then continuing to approve.
And then also this idea,
there's,
this is a really important one because
people have this idea that somehow I'm
30 years old,
I shouldn't be doing this anymore.
I'm 50 years old.
I should have learned by now.
That's all bullshit.
Throw that away,
tossed that shit aside.
You like these ideas of numbers that
people have in their head that by a
certain age you should stop.
You are alive.
And if you are alive,
and if you were thinking all those
numbers that you keep attaching,
will you know when Einstein was 30 here,
shut the fuck up,
stop doing that.
That that is a waste of your time and
stop saying to yourself,
I should be better by now.
I'm such a total non helping thought
what you need to think of his life.
You're living,
you're alive right now.
And if you've made a mistake and you're
still continuing to learn and grow,
that's all just data.
But the thing that freaks me out the
most about rockhold is the flexibility
and dexterity of his legs.
That takes so long to develop that kind
of whip.
You know,
like his kicks aren't just hard.
Like Weidman has strong kicks,
their strong,
like he throws him,
but there's a stiffness to him that
rockwell doesn't have.
Rock holds got like a taekwondo thing
going big.
Yeah.
It isn't a sake.
He was 16 and in,
in San Jose when we were hanging out,
I said,
how much do you weigh?
Sixty eight.
Of course I did.
I took a mounted in your face.
I took him in and I took him in,
but don't kid yourself.
Had My hand on his back couple times and
either Brian came back from hanging out.
Lewis had got his haircut just like him.
I went,
the fuck you doing.
He goes around Luke,
so I wanted to get my hair like I'm
like,
you're 48
copying.
I look him in the eye and I went,
got exactly like luke when we go to a
bar and I looked at my window and we
caught eyes and I looked at my.
When I told you,
and he goes,
he smiled and he went six,
three and I go,
of course you are,
and I looked at his hair and I go deeper
with your voice where we're at a moment
guys.
We had a moment here.
Then I went right to super gods for $12
on my gut and I looked at a picture of
Luke rockhold that you fucking try and
fingers my friend Tarek who trains luke
goes,
hey,
counts here.
I think you'd suck luke steak.
We ask them did you can take.
You can take.
I think out of that sentence,
all right,
I'll do it just as a coop.
Don't tell anybody.
I think by and large people can have the
perspective that you have.
They can say,
well,
looks to me like everybody did it.
So okay.
Uh,
then they can look to the line and they,
that's where they really start to not
like it.
They said this guy lied to us
repeatedly,
but of course you get my,
there's no defense to that.
But if I could,
if I could share any personal insight.
I mean,
once you lie,
once you just keep lying,
you keep saying this is,
if I'm going to sit here,
you know,
this is 15 years ago and Joe,
you're a nice guy and you.
I mean if I was on this podcast,
I would allied to your fucking face a
million times.
Just so you know,
I have just show you now,
just so you know,
that's not a surprise to you or anybody
else,
but once you're in there,
it's not as if I'm going to go,
you know,
this Guy Joe seems like a really nice
guy.
I think I'm going to be real,
I'm going to be honest with him,
too much money.
There's no way you can't once that.
Yeah.
So I was,
I was stuck,
for lack of a better word in that,
uh,
in that lie or that deception,
but then the way that I took my
competitive nature,
which served me well in training and in
racing and took it into the real world,
took it into a press conference,
took it into a personal relationship,
took it into former teammates.
My relationship with that.
That's the part where people go,
okay,
fuck this guy forever.
I'm done.
And so,
um,
that,
you know,
you've got sort of three phases.
None of them are good,
but as it got further away,
um,
that,
you know,
lack of respect for others is the thing
that totally fucked me.
And you know,
too that I would,
I would say to anybody that I understand
and,
and um,
I may be in their time out forever.
Um,
I have,
uh,
the only thing I will add that,
that,
that may sound like I'm trying to defend
myself as I've,
I've tried to make amends with all those
people,
right?
The ones that we all know,
the ones people talk about,
I've traveled the world,
I've sat with them,
I've,
I've looked them in the eyes and said
what I did was totally unacceptable that
I'm sorry.
Um,
and almost everybody has accepted the
apology and we've moved on.
Um,
but that doesn't get to this,
this,
this crowd of people that you can't sit
with face to face and you can't say
you're sorry.
I mean,
I can talk to you,
we can talk about it.
Some people may view that as an apology
or,
or not,
but,
but the ones that I could go sit with,
I did.
And that's all that I would add to that.
And I,
and I,
I mean,
I'm proud that most of those people,
and I say most,
not everybody because not everybody's
ready,
but most of those people said,
you know what,
we're good,
we're done.
And so,
uh,
if there was my son and he acted that
way,
first of all,
I'd say the fuck you doing,
you can't act that way.
But I had no,
nobody was standing over me going,
dude,
what are you,
what do you,
you're acting like an asshole.
Nope,
nobody did that.
So,
but if my son did that,
I would say you get over there and you
make it right with that person.
So that's where it is.
And uh,
here we go.
Well there was a,
like,
what I can only describe as like a gun
bodega,
which is fascinating because it's sold
all these different guns.
Like it might sound like a beautiful
antique,
you know,
Pearl Inlaid revolver that like
someone's dad had,
but then also grenades and stuff and
grenades.
Grenades.
Yeah.
Because,
you know,
in case someone tried to kidnap you,
you could have it grab a fucking.
You're coming with me bitch.
Basically.
Yeah.
So we're walking through this town and
um,
that was,
I think the scariest thing that I ever
did in my life.
But it all turned out fine.
And we got to the media office,
which it was a government building that
they,
that these young men have taken over
when they kicked out the central
government and I'm the director of it,
had been kidnapped by Isis and the young
guys are there,
like watching,
watching soccer because everyone,
everyone loves soccer there.
And it was just,
I don't know,
it's like
this feeling of being in this place
where I'm,
the whole world is both fucking with it
and abandoned it both at once,
you know,
and um,
and anything could happen.
So that was the most dangerous thing
I've ever done.
Like nothing I've ever done was as
dangerous is going to Syria.
But I think the most app personally
disturbing thing was um,
I was in Gaza six months ago I guess.
And I went to [inaudible],
which is this neighborhood that was
completely destroyed by Israel during
protective edge.
Like they bombed it and then they went
in with tanks and then they went in with
bulldozers.
Like,
so it's like flattened and it's just
like gone.
Like,
you know,
you,
you go there and you're like,
this is,
this is a neighborhood that has been
wrecked and a lot of times when you see
houses that have collapsed,
you can see all of the stuff of people's
lives and it like,
you're like,
oh,
there's the cooking pots and there's the
bed and there's all the stuff that's
just trapped in.
And then people,
because there's a big housing shortage,
obviously in Gaza were living in these
bombed out buildings,
you know,
where their home was.
And um,
you know,
with no real like,
or anything.
Like I saw this,
I was walking,
it was kind of scrambling through this
building,
take pictures.
And then I just randomly walked into
what I thought was an abandoned room and
there's like an old guy there,
you know,
hanging out.
And I was like,
I'm really sorry to invade,
invade your home.
And I was just talking to him.
But yeah,
he had had like a baller,
gorgeous home,
you know,
before this.
And now he was just living in a little,
like the wreck of one of the rooms.